it's now time for our scene an unseen
segment tonight where we expose what's
really behind the big cultural stories
of the day on the day after the
Philadelphia Eagles would have
celebrated their Super Bowl win at the
White House the team coach held a press
conference
bori didn't address was as newsworthy as
what he did Fox News contributor New
York Times bestselling author Raymond
Arroyo here to explain Raymond this has
been wild well the Eagles won the Super
Bowl obviously the White House wanted to
commend them have an honor for them but
the White House felt the rug was pulled
out from under them 80 players said we
will attend and at the last minute they
said two players will attend and a
mascot and the coach so well and the
coach well the White House said no we're
not doing this now coach Peterson is
trying to explain of the Eagles watch
this our organization and I was looking
forward to going down and being
recognized as world champions and you
know it is what it is I'm not discussing
it it's over coach Peterson should ask
his own is it Patterson Patterson Peters
and Harris Jeffrey Lurie there's the
owner of the team he was the guy who was
recorded in that private NFL owners
meeting trashing Trump I think usually
got a plan
Patterson Peterson is I think he's a
good guy well he there he wanted to be
there and that was genuine when I
watched that whole press conference but
he's sick of this he just wants to play
the guy the organization has explaining
to do why did they pull this fast one on
and by the way the Secret Service has
better things to do than do background
checks on 80 people then disappear so
then oh suddenly what would they have to
do their hair I mean what's the problem
like I don't even plan occurs they
couldn't make it now Stephen Curry who
is the Golden Warriors coach always
weighing in I'm over him to listen
Golden State I've blown away by the
irony of the Eagles being disinvited and
instead we just have these military
sing-alongs at the White House to show
how patriotic we are even though we
don't know the words
it's just incredible who asked him to
wait I haven't heard that much
doublespeak since joy reed tried to
explain those blog entries but here's
the problem with this it's personalizing
your political appetites projecting it
onto the White House if the White House
wants to honor you they're doing that on
behalf of the American people this isn't
personal and it's not even about Trump
now the president would say what is
wrong with the military's long okay you
know sometimes we miss certain words to
certain songs myself included I mean
like maybe week oh I'm dropping right
snarky we got to move on president of
this celebration and two guys decided to
kneel they had video of two guys
kneeling in prayer we haven't we see the
video during the the celebration at the
White House that one now you see I don't
think they're actually kneeling there is
the white shirt and I think this man
gave out from the tonnage it's holding
oh my god look he's blew his MCL there
that's what a co all right now we got
Melania she long night today our
national suspense has ended she appeared
at a FEMA event this is after weeks of
speculation 26 days she was out of the
public eye but nasty people like David
Frum and others were suggesting she was
abused she was knocked around I think he
was trying to save I don't know see this
imagine if the person Pony was saying of
the hypothetical but I don't think you
can say that you don't that was not the
president saluted the first lady that
her first public event today a little
rough patch but she's doing great
and we're very proud of what she's done
a fantastic job as first lady the people
love you people who are country love you
so thank you honey
now we know where in the world Melania
has been she had a kidney operation it
takes time to recover and you know they
can ask the questions but you have to
accept the answers to some of these
people my prayers about this these
people in the media spend it you know
take more time off when they you know
get Botox injections for goodness
there's anything wrong with that well I
haven't had any so I okay any time off
but you know I haven't had any in a
while to put missing posts but missing
person was on there at the pound I mean
by the way
she looked fantastic I love they were
like I loved it out of Africa kind of
thing she had I was I loved it
I think she's she looks great I don't
even want to appear next to her she's so
beautiful oh that's not missing you
that's all I can say all right and then
there was an FBI I got to show you this
video this is it this is an FBI agent in
Colorado he's doing the backflip and it
happens well having fun it's a it's a
nice doing khakis there yeah but it's a
distillery he's on astroturf he flips
his gun falls out boom he shoots an
onlooker and just puts the gun away and
shrugs and kind of goes back to his beer
this these are the same people this is a
cautionary tale people are telling us
don't carry us into a back flip well
they're saying the cautionary tale
people are saying only military and
armed illegal enforcers should have guns
maybe not sometimes civilians do better
with firearms that's a grown man doing a
backflip is that that's a little an FBI
stupid that's okay I am sad okay very
sad I don't think sad to report Raymond
has to be on a single camera she rolled
Jerry Narron
it was the last of the Munchkins from
The Wizard of Oz there he is he was a
member of the lollipop guild who
presented Dorothy with the lollipop I
know you love this movie and Laura thank
you for doing the medley for we
represent the Lollipop Guild the
Lollipop Guild
the lollipop guild and in the name of
the lollipop girl we wish to welcome you
so much Steve
sins were paid less than Toto yeah a
weekly basis Toto made I think 100 bucks
to go munchkins made 35 bucks a week
that was scaled off him he is the last
of 124 munchkins and he's now left us
great at one of the greatest movies of
iconic Wow that's a now you know you how
do I go to Mitch McConnell after this I
rest we're we gotta go